those of you are on course works
received an email saying that expected
you to read the first 92 pages of Robert
Marx's book there'll probably be some
more of that one or two more chapters
and then we will have a take home of
midterm and exam my expectation for the
exam at this moment is that you will be
asked to to appraise the the ways in
which world history since 1500 is
addressed in the textbook that you're
reading and the way that it is addressed
in Robert Marx's book because this is a
question of scale it's a question of of
categories of emphases and so forth and
there's a kind of question that I think
is appropriate of course it also is
educational for me to see how different
approaches to world history work and I
will put a note on coursework to that
effect I know a lot of people are not
here today not because they're
intimidated arraign be because it's Rosh
Hashana I'm sure it's not the rain and
so I will put a note on course worse
than this effect in the last lecture I
talked mostly about Japan and Korea and
China mostly about Korea and Japan
actually and sort of the subtext of that
was the question of how a how a topic
enters the perspective of world history
no the very beginning of this course I
talked about a concern I had with what I
call premature canonization that certain
topics become implanted in the notion of
world history everybody covers the same
topics and yet often it's because those
are traditional focal points that are
picked up from national or regional or
other narratives rather than because
they are intrinsic to some concept of
world history qua world history so those
countries that had a long history of
national expression you know the French
or the English or the know the Muslims
or something like that were more likely
to have a sort of centerpiece stories
that would get rolled into a world
history then countries that have come
rather lately to to historiographical
sophistication in this case Korea and
yet by focusing on the Korea Japanese
confrontation and the imogen war in the
late 16th century as I tried to point
out you've got a sort of a prefiguring
of relationships that will then arise
again in the 20th century with the
Japanese establishing a colonial control
of Korea and seeking to conquer China so
whereas if you talk about the say the
Hundred Years War between between
England and France which everyone will
mention what was the Hundred Years War
between England and France
it was a quarrel between English and
French Kings over who owned what and the
downstream consequences really just
don't add up to a whole lot at the scale
of world history or maybe they do and I
just don't have a sufficient
appreciation of the great achievements
of my ancestors since I have both French
and English background nevertheless I
couldn't I can't see any any big lesson
to be drawn from that war on the other
hand well well this war between Korea
and Japan seems to have a more a greater
consequence in terms of showing the
continuation of relations between States
in East Asia
now I focused on that recognizing and
mentioning that this I was doing for a
chapter that is called northern Eurasia
and I kind of ridiculed the name of the
chapter saying you know it was just sort
of a convenience to find something that
would allow you to cover those empires
you hadn't yet covered in the other
chapters and the result was that you
throw Japan China and Russia into the
same chapter with Korea sandwiched in
between a little bit about the southern
borders of China which are not in
northern Eurasia and then as I was
thinking about it I thought maybe there
should be a chapter on northern Eurasia
when do we ever talk about the North in
world history or for that matter very
much in in national histories if you if
you just sort of thinking categories you
say well let's say here's Western Europe
with the British Isles out here they
deal with each other they deal with the
Atlantic they deal with Spain and France
and so forth
but they have you know there's their
thing any of Western Europe more
generally Mediterranean down here with
its Italy and its Greece and so on
Islamic world but then what do you do
with the north the Vikings have their
moments in the in the Sun when they go
forth and do their Viking thing we tend
to look at the Vikings as if they are
northern barbarians because they raid
the coasts of Ireland and England and
France and ultimately set up States all
the way down to Sicily because the the
Sicilian rulers who participated in the
First Crusade in the end of the 11th
century were Normans who had conquered
Sicily about the same time other Normans
were conquering England under William
the Conqueror and the Normans are simply
those Vikings who settled in Normandy
and northern France so we see them as
Raiders and builders of of kingdoms no
strong Swedish guides with big swords
that sort of thing
horns on the helmets but if you're in
Islamic history what you tend to talk
about is the trade that those same
Vikings were engaged in because there
are tens of thousands of coins that have
been found on islands in the Baltic Sea
and on the mainland in Sweden and on the
mainland in Poland that are Islamic
coins
there are also coins from the Byzantine
Empire but the largest hoards immense
quantity the largest quantities of coins
practically and
we're from the Islamic world our Iranian
coins that show up there in in the
Baltic and what they testify to and what
we have some sources talking about is
the robust trade that went north and
south through what we now call Russia
along the rivers of the Ural River the
Volga River the Don River a whole series
of rivers and this trade was carried out
by Scandinavians who used boats on the
river and who established pounds here
and there as strong points to support
their their commerce and they they
became known as the ruse was the root
word of where we got Russia so you get
another section here that connects the
north down to the Islamic world those
coins those coin hearts pretty much come
to an end
Oh in the 11th century or so in other
words this was a medieval practice once
you get a therel Christianization of the
north you're more likely to have the
trade go to Constantinople than to the
Islamic territories and indeed you start
to have a a military force in Byzantine
Empire and Constantinople who are
protectors of the of the Emperor and
their Swedes
they're known as the Varangians so we we
absorb the Dorothy know the Norwegians
the Danes the Swedes and so forth into
our history of Islam of the Byzantine
Empire of Europe and so forth in the
medieval period because we see these
these connections but as you get to the
early modern period we talk less about
them and not because they become less
less active but somehow their activities
have not sort of made it into the Canon
of things that are talked about
necessarily in world history so I'm
looking at my own book of the one that
you're signed plus are the three main
competitors
I looked for well what do they say about
Ivan the fourth Ivan the Terrible a man
ruling in Russia until his death and
1584 extremely dynamic if terrible ruler
introduced many different you know
unusual practices as a news rule and was
fighting over and over and over again
with Sweden with Denmark and with the
polish-lithuanian Commonwealth these
northern wars were protracted they were
they involved a great deal of
sort of episodes of diplomacy and
episodes of outright warfare the Baltic
Sea was seen as the sort of a target I
mean Russia wanted to have outlets onto
the Baltic Sea and yep these northern
wars don't get talked about much now one
could say well maybe they just don't fit
into what the main story is after all if
the main story of the early modern
period is Renaissance Reformation
discovery of the new world development
of the trade companies particularly the
dusties Dutch East India Company in the
French or the English say East India
Company maybe you know Russia and the
North are simply too far off the map but
the fact of the matter is that Ivan the
fourth had extensive diplomatic
communication with Queen Elizabeth the
first in England you have a series of
embassies going back and forth the
desire of the English was to establish a
trading monopoly in in Russia now that
could be done either by simply well part
of it was having the Czar declare that
the English would be the the only
foreign traders permitted but part of it
was also having a seaport don't they
could go to so the result is that
Archangel archangel sck which is not in
the baltic sea but rather north of there
in territories that that Russia fully
controlled that becomes the point of
entry for the English ships it's just
that it's covered with ice for you know
long sections of the year but the
British were always looking for lumber
for for shipbuilding furs sirs were
probably the most important export that
that the Czar's realm had
in terms of imports with the Czar wanted
was modern weaponry so this becomes
another part of this gunpowder evolution
the bringing of or the request by Ivan
the fourth to have cannon founders and
weapons specialists come from England to
Russia and help give the Russian armies
a you know a better chance in these wars
against the the poles Lithuanians the
Danes and the Swedes there was more
contact between Russia and and England
than there was say between Russia and
Iran but the British ambassador I'll
present sin Iran in the form of Anthony
Shirley in particular is more likely to
get mentioned in the world history
textbooks then what's happening here in
the north
after Ivan dies you do have a Time of
Troubles
in Russia this coincides chronologically
with the onset of the so-called Little
Ice Age so that things are getting
unpleasant in Russia in ways that Ivan's
terribleness had not was not entirely
responsible for it he he had had a
disagreement with his oldest son at one
point and so he killed him because he
always carried around an iron staff and
he just got angry and he hit his son
with the staff a few days later the son
died of the wound and Ivan was very
contrite and did all sorts of penances
but it left him with only one son Fyodor
who was mentally and physically weak and
he became the Tsar he never had any sons
and so the the dynasty that had been
originated by a swede named Rick who was
one of the routes that dynasty comes to
an end after a few years when Fyodor
dies and that's the end of the dynasty
that Ivan fourth have been part of you
then get the brother-in-law takes over a
man who oddly enough we all have heard
of Boris scooted off he becomes the Tsar
and obviously is a person of great
importance because there's an opera
about him you know there are stories
about him you know Boris good enough we
know that's a name from Marseilles but
he doesn't show up really in the world
history textbooks because he's an opera
he's about a real person
but after Boris good enough rules then
you have a real mess until you have in
the early 1600s you have a new Tsar who
was chosen by the aristocrats and his
name is Mikkel Romanoff and that's the
origin of the Romanov dynasty that then
rules until the Russian Revolution and
Mikhail Romanov had been one of the one
of the Regents who sort of ran the the
Empire during Theodore's brief period as
our and he had been a close to Ivan the
fourth but in Russian history you say
well you you come up to Ivan the
Terrible then you get the Time of
Troubles and then things get back on
some kind of track with Mikhail Romanoff
who looks to the west to other parts of
Europe in some ways and you know not add
I finally got Peter the Great and now
Russia enters world history with Peter
the Great as Peter the Great
introduces Western ways to Russia if you
were writing the history of the modern
world as the history of the triumph of
the West this may make a lot of sense in
which you say the crucial thing is
westernization the crucial thing is how
did other people learn from and imitate
the Europeans in the long run with the
development of European imperialism you
might make a plausible argument for this
but if you're talking about the 1600s
European imperialism isn't yet that
world-spanning phenomenon that it would
become in the 1700s and even more in the
1800s in other words if you're going to
to say that Europeanisation
is the thing that warrants inclusion in
your cannon of world historical events
you know how early do you start that you
know or is this simply a matter of
glorifying Europe and singling it out as
being peculiarly excellent in terms of
science in terms of humanism in terms of
ultimately a political organization and
religious toleration and so forth and
all those good things that Europeans
European historians like to associate
with Europe so Peter the Great becomes
an important person and the historians
normally leave out Ivan the fourth
despite the fact that he was terrible
and that everyone's heard of him
I mean of famous people in history he's
one of the most notable was being left
out since everybody has heard of Ivan
the Terrible and nobody knows who in the
world he was but that's if you're going
to follow that that story the story of
the rise of of Western Europe and say
that is the story of modern history but
under Ivan the fourth you also had the
beginnings of a very different story
that applies to Russia and that is the
expansion of Russia eastward into let's
say beyond the Ural Mountains and into
inner Asia the primary opponents of Ivan
in his in the early parts of his reign
were the remnants of the Mongols who
were still ruling to the south and in
fact the whole emergence of Moscow as
the capital compared with the pre Mongol
capital of Kiev which was now in the in
the Ukraine the whole idea of having a
capital so much farther north
was a result of the fact that the
Mongols occupied the south and those
independent Slovak you know figures who
had been powerful before the Mongols
came either had to become subordinate to
the Mongols or they had to move to the
northern fringe
so when Yvonne starts out he's fighting
against the Crimean Tatars the no guys
and other Tatar thatis a Mongol groups
and and usually it's given to us Tatar
now does tartar tartar is what you put
in egg whites when you make meringue you
put in cream of tartar and I'm sure
that's not a cream of a Mongol or
something better and I don't know why
tartar sauce is called tartar sauce but
but the term that historians use is
Tatar so ivan was fighting against the
the tatars he conquers two of the realms
of the tatars letter to his east
pastor Han and cuz I'm yes no it started
with K so he conquers Astro huh and
Kazan and their dubious conquests I mean
he'll take one and that'll be thrown out
it's a very dynamic border of this is
also on the pot our borders East and
South that you get bands of soldiery who
are sort of free individuals there the
Cossacks some of them are Christians
some of it are Muslims they're sort of
freely self-governing free
self-governing bands that in and enter
into military alliance with various
states including Eve on the
the eastern boundary doesn't have
anything like the clear definition in
two kingdoms that you have in the
western boundary where you can say
Swedes have this and they want this the
Danes have this they want that the pol
polish Lithuanian Commonwealth is here
and it wants so the thing and the east
things seem to be much more much more
fluid by the time that Yvonne dies
Russians have moved deeply into Siberia
not in particular in relation to the two
to Czarist efforts but rather as private
traders particularly looking for furs
and they have defeated some of the
indigenous peoples of siberia and in the
early 1600s russians reach all the way
to the Pacific Ocean
we mention this but we don't mention it
in the way we talk about Americans
subdue in the West in other words it's
they're extremely similar processes
going on at the same time and you have
very large areas that are inhabited by
very small populations in the Russian
case because they are so far to the
north that agriculture is limited and
difficult in the North American case not
only is it far far north in the case of
northern United States and Canada but
it's also because of the decimation of
the indigenous population by disease but
in any case you have frontiersman fur
trappers adventurers
who are traveling out into these areas
with minimal connection with the
government and capturing continent-wide
territories for their home territory in
other words when you have you'll have a
you know Russian merchant adventurers
will come to Yvonne and say guess what
you're now the ruler of Siberia you know
please accept it into your realm and he
didn't do anything for it
but to some degree this is the big story
at this time in the same way that Canada
and the inland parts of the United
States are the big story that is going
on in the 1600s more than the 1500s in
North America these two phenomena the
spread of the Russians across Siberia
and the spread of the American colonists
and then the American citizens across
the Americas across North America and
the Canadians as well these set up the
great the great opposition that you
finally get in the cold war because this
is how you get to polities or to to
polities on the one side the United
States and Canada one policy and the
other that are so very much larger than
the others the only traditional polity
that can compete in terms of scale is
China but it's these two new territories
that are
that develop into the future superpowers
of the world now you would think that if
you are doing the history of the rise of
modern world that the formation of the
superpowers would be your your Telos
will be objective no and if you were
conceiving of this during the Cold War
when you would say you have one great
land power in the east and one great
land power in the West taking Canada
here as being our sort of faithful
cousins let's explain how these came
into being but we don't really do that
we explain how one of them came into
being you know the glorious story of the
rise of America with its Canadian
cousins and then we we sort of taken as
given well and then of course Russia
took over everything in northern Eurasia
without but of course it didn't it
didn't take over northern Eurasia west
of Russia the Swedes
the Scandinavians the Danes the poles
all the poles lose out in the 1790s but
then they come roaring back in the late
19th century but but basically all of
this absorption of northern Eurasia into
a single polity takes place with Russia
but Russia does not successfully expand
into northern Eurasia toward the west
the
it does not expand into the southern
part in other words you think here let's
deal with inner Asia
here's Tibet in the southern part you
have deserts and trade routes the things
that we know that the things that we now
associate with the independent countries
of Uzbekistan Kazakhstan Kyrgyzstan
Tajikistan and and Mongolia other words
if you if you would divide inner Asia
North and South the southern part does
not fall into Russian hands at this time
it's the northern part it really is
northern Eurasia that becomes subject to
to Russian occupation
we don't talk about it partly because
there are no great states to be
conquered population is very sparse
partly because the the economic
potential of this region is not realized
within the timeframe of the you know of
the pre 20th century world and yet the
consequences of this of this massive
addition of territory are are truly
enormous the Russians who are barely
able to put a ship on the water in the
West at all because our Archangel is so
so terribly limited by ice and in the
Black Sea which they finally get there
long after Ivan's death they still
cannot go through the Straits into the
Mediterranean so Russia gets very little
access to ocean transport except in
Vladivostok which is on the Pacific
coast which can develop into an
important Russia Russian seaport
Vladivostok to this day is the most
southerly city in Russia because you
know Russia now to the south
it has Ukraine it has these various
countries ending in stam but on the
Pacific coast Vladivostok is becomes an
important seaport and ultimately you get
the confrontation that is going to
develop between Russia and Japan in 1905
and the Russell Japanese war now in a
sense what's interesting here is that
why wasn't China the great adversary in
this
China was a huge Empire by Empire I mean
that it had people speaking different
languages or following different faiths
it was dominated by one ethnic group
Chinese known as the Han but China
doesn't compete very strongly with
Russia there's a almost an unspoken
division of territory so that China will
expand into this area the southern part
of the inner Asian no landmass and
Russia will expand into the northern
part so at the end of the 1500s you have
the first the first recognition of a
Dalai Lama I think it's the fourth Dalai
Lama becomes the Paramount religious
figure in Tibet by the time you get to
the fifth sixth seventh Dalai Lama's
Tibet is on its way to becoming
subordinate to to China this is a huge
development in Tibetan religion with the
rise of the Dalai Lama and the religious
history of Tibet bills is fascinating in
this period but in terms of politics
this is when China begins to make its
big claim that continues to this day
upon sovereignty over Tibet the Chinese
continue to struggle against mongols to
their north
not the powerful mongols of the era of
jenga's khan but but a surviving Mongol
Kingdom to the north and increasingly
they are confronted by a new power
rising in the Northeast in Manchuria
which is a largely forested region that
produces the armies of horse warriors
but is not part of the old Chinese
central you know civilized my Chinese
definition region
the Manchus take over in China in 1644
and from then until 1923 you have a
ruling family that is nominally of
Manchu origin and in the early periods
of the of the Manchus we this is what's
known as the Qing Dynasty you have
Manchu culture remaining intact special
territories singled out for maintaining
the Manchu Army efforts to to prevent
there being a complete absorption of the
Manchus into the Han Chinese customs for
example a Manchu women do not bind their
feet
whereas Han women do the Han Chinese men
are expected to wear a queue of a
pigtail the Manchu men do not so forth
and so on
so so China has difficulties due north
Mongolia and Manchuria it has problems
in the south it obviously has problems
in the east because Japan is is
confrontational
particularly under Hideyoshi and then it
becomes less confrontational you know
during the Tokugawa period that follows
the death of Hideyoshi but due west the
Chinese don't do badly they are able to
to expand along the old Silk Road into
the territory that sound out as a Shin
Jang if you look at older books this is
the region known as a sin kyon older
British sources followed a
transliteration system that that had
fallen out of step with phonetic changes
that were occurring in the Chinese
language so that the K that was
pronounced as a as we opened out that K
had evolved into a J sound so that this
is why you have older sources will pay
say Peking and now we say Beijing
Nanking becomes nanjing Chung King
becomes Chung Jing the P was moving in
the direction of becoming a B so that
Peking is now Beijing because the P has
become a B and so forth and and these
are directional though these just
directional terms you know BAE is North
and the South so on so so Xin Zhong
becomes brought into this Chinese Empire
Andrey and even though it is occupied
although the native population is
primarily turkic-speaking it becomes a
territory for
for the extension of Chinese culture and
Chinese economy now the difference
between the northern part of this inner
Asian area in other words the north the
Eurasia area of Siberia
where this where the Russians are going
and the area to the south of it where
the Chinese are extending their their
power as they have done from time to
time in earlier periods of world history
the main difference is that the
populations of the north are very sparse
and economically have very simple
economies in some areas particularly the
farther as you go north farther you you
find a reindeer based economy and you
can look at the index of world history
textbooks they don't say much about
reindeer but reindeer should not be
should not be ignored they were and
continue to be the basis of economies in
far north far north areas all the way
from Norway across to across to the
Pacific Ocean and the northern eurasia
and also into the Aleutian Islands in
Alaska and northern Canada we have a we
have a very very poor history of how
that came about there are some theorists
who feel that reindeer may have been the
original domestic animals and others who
say no reindeer must have come along
late in the game
what makes this complicated is that the
reindeer are
not domestic animals in the full sense
of the word that we use for cattle or
horses something like that in other
words people who herd raindeers newer
reindeer
the reindeer migrate and the people who
heard them migrate with them but they
don't it isn't like you're leading them
to fresh pasture as you would with sheep
or goats or horses or camels or
something if that they're going where
they want to go and you're tagging along
but they're fine with that
they have no objection for you being
with them and if you want to milk them
you know milk them if you want to hook
them to your sleds hook them to your
sleds if you want to ride them put on a
saddle and ride them the reindeer the
this great distinction what is the
difference between a wild reindeer and
an investigator even the reindeer
herders are not very clear as to what
the difference is they say oh well you
know you know commenting Cupid over here
are domestic and I hooked them to my
sled but you know Donner and Blitzen are
kind of wild and so you know it's it's
very ambiguous but it gets into to the
question of how people interact with
with animals and in general animals that
have no predators can be virtually tame
in a wild state so that camels were
probably never had to be domesticated
very much they were living out in the
middle of a desert nobody ate camel and
so the camels were not flighty in the
way that gazelles for example are but
that doesn't work terribly well for
reindeer because reindeer are are the
primary prey of wolves and you have a
symbiotic relationship between between
reindeer and wolves
so they are not they're not top
predators they're not devoid of of being
prey animals themselves and yet they
appear to have been more easily
accommodated into human lifestyles than
most of the domestic animals we have so
this is where the argument comes in is
that because they represent an early
stage of domestication you know
intermediate between wild and fully
domestic that became sort of frozen or
perpetuated in the in northern Eurasia
because that was the form that the
environment could sustain that in other
words they were not being drawn into
grain farming or don't providing meat
for large cities because there were no
large cities is do the reindeer herders
represent an early form of human animal
relation or are they a late form that is
derivative in some way from the others
the number of scholars who pursue this
particular question you know there may
be six sorry but this isn't a big issue
I may be making more of it the night
than I ought but I would I would point
out that one of the interesting things
in this is that if you look at the way
that that oxen are harnessed to to plows
or to ox carts or if you look at the way
that horses are harnessed for labour
pulling wagons and carts in Central Asia
or in northern China or in Russia and
then you look at the way it's done with
reindeer it's different the reindeer
it does not look as though these
utilities secondary utilities to which
reindeer are are adapted does not look
as they're as though they're derivative
from what you have with cattle or horses
because they don't use the existing
technology and you cannot look at a
reindeer harness and say oh that clearly
derives from a from a horse collar or a
the yoke used for oxen the closest thing
to it as far as I can tell are the
harness was used by sled dogs among the
Eskimos which then gets into the
question of well even though we done
never had domestic reindeer in North
America did the notion of utilizing
animals that we find with the reindeer
carry over into the use of dogs in North
America and if there were six people
really interested in reindeer
domestication well once we get down to
comparing reindeer harness with dog
harness or pretty much down to one this
is not again a very hot issue the reason
I bring it up is because there is a very
very very substantial difference in in
economic level historical consciousness
national or ethnic identity a much
higher level down here in the southern
part of inner Asia than in the northern
part so that today you will have the a
Chinese government that finds it
extremely difficult to maintain orderly
rule in Shin Jang and in and in Tibet
because you have religious traditions
and you have language
literate language traditions I do you
have ethnic identities and you have
national histories that go back to
before the period that that is used to
substantiate the Chinese claims so the
the area that the that China expands
into particularly during the period that
this chapter covers is an area that
comes to be contestant if the the
Chinese rule but the Han Chinese do not
have a uncontested domination at a more
localized level the the Turks in Shin
Jang the Tibetans clearly maintain a
different identities and as we get into
the 20th century developed extreme
resentment against the Han Chinese
settlers that move into these
territories increasingly in recent
decades to the north mongolia remains
intensely anti anti chinese the the
several years ago my son spent three
months in alon bot or working on a
microfinance with a bank there and he
said his mongolian friends who mean that
would say what's your favorite food in
the united states and he would say i
like to order chinese they'd say that's
disgusting you know who would eat
Chinese food Chinese foods it can you
like everything else Chinese I mean and
it was just sort of a gut reflex that
the China had this representative
hostility I mean say oh well you know
true there is a chain of Mongolian
barbecue places now that that's a a
modern chain that is not drawn into all
of this
Russia on the other hand was by and
large pretty successful in establishing
the dominance of ethnic Russians over
the peoples in the areas that it
occupied so that even though many of our
least some of those peoples did not
convert to Christianity some did some
did not but they generally gained access
to literacy through Russians devising
Cyrillic alphabets for writing their
languages so that whether you're talking
about the severe the people for whom
Siberia is named or the koryaks or the
semi Ed's or whatever you don't you
don't have this this ethnic dimension it
doesn't mean that you don't have
nationalism ultimately showing up the
present day you have groups in
post-soviet Siberia who have identities
that they try to link with other
identities through you know um
Commission's talking about you know
non-sovereign minorities in different
parts of the world but by and large the
dominance of the rush of the Russians is
accepted in the way that the dominance
of European immigrants the United States
and Canada comes to be accepted by
Native Americans despite the fact that
they still have their own traditions
their own histories and so on their own
casinos so that again you have a
similarity between Russia and United
States and Canada in terms of
establishing an ethnic hegemony you
might want to call it over
area and China which is doing something
rather similar is not achieving the same
end because the the long tradition of
the Silk Road and the independence of
the Central Asian peoples of the
southern part of this northern Eurasia
stands in the way of China achieving the
same or the Chinese as a seeing the same
degree of of domination this extends
somewhat into Japan the northernmost
island island of Japan it was Hokkaido
it very much fits into the northern
eurasia pattern that is to say it's very
cold has lots of snow and until fairly
recent times was occupied primarily by
people who were then called I knew
there's a there's a more current name
for the I knew I can't bring it to mind
at the moment but they are considered to
be a primordial occupant of the Japanese
islands on the only place where the Ainu
remain are in are in Hokkaido
you do eventually get Japanese settlers
going into the north into Hokkaido
mainly coming from Northwest Honshu the
island just to the south which has a
very snowy and cold climate so they can
move into Hokkaido without too much
difference but but Hokkaido becomes a
kind of a semi mythical land you'll see
it's not like quite like the American
West but it is it's different for one
thing you have large areas where you
have herds of animals you don't have
herds of animals and the other Japanese
islands japanese by large live on
protein from the sea rather than protein
from herd so you'll have horse herds and
cow herds in in Hokkaido that you would
not have in most other parts of Japan
you also have a among the the native
population the I know a tradition of
writing reindeer there are two things
that I would anyone who wants to pursue
this I would recommend looking at one of
them is the movie Princess Mononoke
which is set in this area and where the
hero rides a reindeer and there's a very
strong Chamonix and Buddhist undertones
to it and the other is a novel by Haruki
Murakami called
a wild sheep chase which deals with a
with sheep and effort by Japanese
militarists of 1930s to introduce sheep
herding into Japan into Hokkaido in
order to have wool that could be used
for winter uniforms for the Japanese
army for when they were going to next
invade Korea and China
it's just that in work
his story among the sheep that they
brought in for this purpose and and
historically it was true they did bring
in sheep for this purpose at that time
Morikami says they were all they brought
in one bad sheep an evil sheep he was
the Sheep who had spiritually entered
into the mind of jenga's khan who set
off to who will the world and once he
gets to Japan he enters into the mind of
a Japanese militarists who ends up being
a class-a war criminal and and the whole
story is how a current neo-fascist
industrialist in japan has hired this
Morikami sort of typical rootless hero
to go and find the evil sheep because he
wants to have a mind meld
with this evil sheep so that he can
restore fascism in Japan and it's a it's
quiet I happen to be a big fan of
Morikami it's a terrific novel and but
it also has very strong elements of
shamanism in it because there's a sheep
man in it who is half sheep half human
dresses as a sheep visit the Sheep says
baa-baa baa-baa but he also can
communicate with people but also it it
builds a kind of myth that militarism in
Japan is not native to Japan it's an
import from those awful Mongols or from
the West anyway it's not native to Japan
how he missed the history of the samurai
I'm not sure but but it it really speaks
to a certain construction of the whole
history of Japan in which World War two
becomes an anomaly rather than something
something that is interior to to
Japanese history so it's very much a
novel worth reading but I digress
what I've been trying to do here is to
talk about this whole notion of a
northern eurasia in terms of standard
political history you simply don't have
any big landmarks you know
the Manchus invade China you know Yvonne
the forth rules in Russia but in between
is there anything happening that
commands the attention of your world
political historian no names leap out is
there anything that commands the
attention of your world economic
historian say well actually the Silk
Road doesn't seem to have continued to
be very very dynamic we simply don't
have evidence of the huge camel caravans
in the exchange of goods all the way
across from China to the Mediterranean
that we had in earlier centuries so the
area appears to become unimportant but
that that goes to to the root of the
question of how do you decide what to
talk about in world history if you have
an area that is going to become
critically important as northern Eurasia
does become in the 20th and 21st
centuries or as the United States and
Canada become on the western hemisphere
do you not talk about them because they
don't have a a nice narrative arc they
don't have hallmark names that you can
easily remember and know talk about or
do you simply say it just happened that
these huge expanses of land came under
the control of
the United States and Canada Russia and
in the southern part of the Eurasia of
northern Eurasia China that these things
just happened and then when we get down
to to the 20th century we deal with the
who is sort of a federal complete the
this is this is what happened in a sense
while we were looking at other things or
do we put this this story in at the
present time increasingly I think it's
very difficult to leave this story out
you can look at and I I know people who
are very actively looking at this matter
in the world of finance in the world of
business who are saying the greatest
open resource Zone in the world totally
unexploited or nearly unexploited is is
northern Eurasia both in the southern
area going down toward Afghanistan then
all the way north to the Arctic Circle
Russia today has a an economy that is
largely buoyed up by oil from Siberia by
petroleum resources
China's near stranglehold on rare earths
which are essential to to all sorts of
devices that people associate with the
next phase of energy conversion those
rare earths are out there in in Shin
Jang they're out in
in the Central Asian part where else do
you go to get rare earths it turns out
biggest concentration of rare earths
outside of Chinese control is probably
in those Beca Stan where I have a source
who feeds me the information on this who
is very much involved in trying to
arrange ways to connect American and
Turkish and Japanese financiers and
industrialists with the corrupt
governments of Central Asia to exploit
the resources of of this area and to get
there before the Chinese do that's
interesting now you're beginning to have
people casting this as a as a new
struggle will it be the Chinese coming
in or will it be the Russians or will be
the Turks coming up from here who is
going to get get these riches now right
now it's kind of supposition but when
you look at world history what do you
often find is that where the main
economic activity is is where the wars
are because when you have interests that
are powerful economic interests that get
associated with with the national
interest this is when you get the kinds
of conflicts that lead to that lead to
Wars there's not a single person I know
of in the US government who believes
that we went war in Iraq for oil and I
don't know of a single person in the
world outside of government who believes
that we did not go to war in Iraq in
some way for oil I happen to agree with
the government people
I don't think that's why we went to war
in Iraq but it is interesting that the
the presumably unanticipated benefit of
a war in Iraq is that we now are pretty
much the sole lorne owners of the
country of Qatar which hat which is one
of the four three or four biggest
holders of natural gas in the entire
world because the country's invited us
to make that the headquarters of our
Central Command so that we would defend
the Gulf and its oil resources from
Qatar and since we were in Qatar the
Saudis couldn't take it over so the
countries can stick their fingers in the
Saudi eye by broadcast on al-jazeera and
they know that the Saudis can't do a
damn thing about it because we're there
and we could actually as far as I can
tell we could legitimately within the
understandings from the United States
and Qatar put more uniformed military
personnel on the ground in Qatar than
the entire adult male native population
of the country of Qatar because there
are only about 12 thousand citizens
adult male citizens in Qatar they claim
more but you know you just can't
they couldn't have multiplied that fast
almost everyone Qatar is an immigrant
who was hired to do work and they have
to go home they can't become citizens
and but then the US has its army there
so the main airport has like revetment
for 300 military aircraft and the entire
Air Force of Qatar is under a hundred no
it's just become an American an American
military base in many respects which
also hosts and finances the one
television station that nobody in this
country will put on the air because it's
supposedly anti-american ill Jazeera so
you go figure but whether it is in the
19th century the
the idea of wars that would involve
Britain's route to India the source of
Britain's wealth or whether it is
resource Wars that we have in the 20th
century like Germany's invasion of the
USSR during World War 2 in order to try
and seize the oil resources of what is
now azar bhaijaan down on the Caspian
Sea because otherwise the German war
machine would would grind to a halt
you know Wars and resource competition
are very very closely related
historically so now as we see resource
competition arising in this area it may
just be a question of time before this
metastasizes into into some sort of
situation of violence and the fact that
the Pakistanis have nuclear weapons and
the Iranians what nuclear weapons and we
have basing agreements with all sorts of
people I mean we're we're getting ready
for for the future I mean they hate to
be quite so negative about it when I was
editing the Columbia history of the 20th
century and I wanted to have one chapter
on war in the 20th century I went to
several specialists to write that
chapter and they pretty much everyone I
talked to a specialist on history of war
sent worker I said war is over because
there is no longer any need or desire
for one country to seize land belonging
to another country wars were efforts to
seize land or seize population those
things are now obsolete
hence war as we know it is over though
we may have you know
incidents you know little gorillas or
people flying airliners into skyscrapers
or something like that but I think that
this may be know may turn out to be to
be wrong now I mean why would I
emphasize something like this which is
just entirely speculative other than to
spit out the time well the reason is
that if we get resource competition
becoming politically significant in this
part of the world then we're going to
have to write this part of the world
back into world history we're gonna have
to say okay how did the modern world
come into being the modern world
involves who owns the oil in the Caspian
Sea and you know people who are going to
go to war over it now you have to write
back and go back and see how you get
that into your world history so when
this chapter was proposed by by my
colleague who drafted it and he said I
will write a chapter called northern
Eurasia and you write a chapter called
southern Eurasia which ended up my being
my chapter on Southwest Asia and India
or whatever he was very annoyed that I
did not use the term southern Eurasia
the chapter he wrote is a history of
Japanese culture and politics Chinese
culture and politics Russian culture and
politics it isn't really a chapter in
northern Eurasia but what I decided
after thinking about this for the last
couple of weeks is that maybe there
should be a chapter in northern Eurasia
and one in which we we don't stick
simply to to the landmarks to the big
names to the to the recognized Canon of
of events but rather we deal with it
more more conceptually in this notion of
dealing with world history conceptually
and the inherent conflict that can
between that and dealing with it in
terms of of a more positive as narrative
more a series of facts is what is going
to underlie the the examination question
for the midterm comparing the work of
Robert Marx with the textbook that we
have so that's it for today thank you
in the Altai mountains or whatever it is
they came from where you have multiple
Turkic dynasties you know the Ottoman
subjects of many dynasties do they have
anything like that in Asia